afida turner était aussi une des grandes
révélations de ce soir j'ai baba le 2
avril dernier je pense que si elle ne
l'est plus gros fous rires de l'histoire
de mon de l'histoire de mon histoire à
la télévision je dis la vérité
elle avait décidé de pousser un grand
coup de gueule car pour elle le
coronavirus était un complot je crois
que cette séquence est culte on vous a
préparé un petit récap regardez c'est un
des plus gros sourire de ma vie regardez
c'est le 2 avril dernier que cyril avait
décidé de donner la parole à afida
turner dans l'émission un passage très
remarqué qui a créé le buzz sur les
réseaux car il faut le dire afida n'a
pas sa langue dans sa poche et elle n'a
pas hésité à donner en direct son avis
sur le coronavirus etc depuis miami que
la jeune femme a décidé d'intervenir
pour donner l alerte
et à en croire sa tenue a donné l'
alerte à malibu je sais que c'est c'est
quelque chose que l'on sait c'est l'art
c'est un coup d'état au monde bancaire
etc vous emmener une intervention que
cyril a su prendre très au sérieux tout
comme christophe barbier son écharpe
rouge sur bfm
afida et son maillot rouge a su livrer
une analyse poussée de la situation
effectivement est en relation avec des
très grands présidents de différents
pays
mon est écrit mendient afida
effectivement tu as une très grande
confiance et rend la défense et
bienveillance peut-être pas un grand
moment pour la science mais sûrement un
grand moment de fou rire mais ça je peux
le revoir sans voix alors on va revoir
donc ça a démarré
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai vu s'ouvrir je
vais vous dire pourquoi pas ce qu'on va
voir ce passage où le ton est très vite
monté entre afida turner et matthieu
delormeau regarder et c'est après que
moi je vous dis la vérité vient pas
d'abord soutenir une théorie du complot
avec une coupe de champagne et en
maillot de bain avec des idées qui sont
sortis de ton décolleté avec un médecin
qui 30 dans la raie des fesses pour pour
obtenir des aides pourtant des théories
pareil ça n'a aucun sens une bugatti
surmaturité mathieu deux minutes je vais
défendre afida de 2nde nature on était
les premiers à et en fous rires donc
s'il vous plaît écoutez comme un trou du
cul à la ville mais comme un trou du cul
un énorme avec un énorme trou du cul
vous ne travaillez pas au point et vous
ne travaillez pas au cdrs et n'y allez à
là c'est pas coeur de lille hockey de
lanvaux moi je vous adore
on a fait des parties ont maintenu quant
aux délais
je n'ai jamais reçu un chèque faucheurs
et en images vous plaît à comment là il
faut changer de métier avait travaillé à
l'institut pasteur fait des vaccins
allaient travailler pour house façon à
vous pourrez peut-être vous pourriez
peut-être donner un avis moi je pense
que tu es venu avec ton maillot de bain
en sortant des théories aberrante et
complotistes uniquement pour pouvoir
derrière car ce que tu as fait c'est à
dire marquer sur instagram que al qaida
turner faisait le buzz par l'ema que
pour avoir de la visibilité qu'on te
voit et qu'on parle de toi car tu ne vis
que de ça du buzz et de ton image alors
je dois vous dire moi on m'a dit qu'un
field à turner ce soir et quand je me
connecte avec elle un moment je veux dit
bon je vais voir une personne voilà
voilà de l'habiller comme renier comme
toujours et c'est vrai que je quand j'ai
vu afida dans son body
voilà j'ai eu un moment de voilà deux
voilà deux je me suis dis bah c'est
quand même quelque chose quoi et c'est
là de là qu'est parti le fou rire
regardez je crois que je peux le revoir
mme une fois c'est un des plus gros fous
rires que j'ai eu au téléphone
je comprends que des gens qui puissent
être choqués et toi qu'est l'état
théorique sur le virus en fait les
séries sont arrivés marc et sinon il
m'aurait on apprend même ce que tu dis
[Rires]
je le dis aux téléspectateurs regardent
et le pop art ou un moment me parle et
j'ai c'est de redevenir sérieux donc je
me redresse est choqué et toi quelle est
ta théorie sur le virus en fait les
séries on a je comprends l'homme que tu
nies peu plus parce que tu as raison
mais bon elle me dit alban gueule et moi
je reviens et de sérieux je suis encore
[Rires]
un but tout en sourire parce que vous
l'entendez mal ou du chômage quelques
jours mais afida est revenu sur le
plateau pour avoir un droit de réponse
et là nous annoncer une chose énorme
regardez ce que vous nous avez annoncé
afida je sais pas voilà si ça réussit ou
pas mais regardez
elle profite néanmoins de villa en vente
à 15 nuls à quinze mille balles tu as
fait quoi quand rien sauf que moi je
peux faire tout beau d'ici là nous et on
a vu les corps en tant qu'unique parce
que ton âme énorme pouvoir son chef de
file
mais bon alors du bon ton maillot de
bain 15000 euros
oui faut bien aider les gens j'ai pas
entendu il faut il faut bien aider les
gens oui je le veux je m'en vais ouais
non c'était pas un magasin c'était un
beau 10 c'est le afida tombeau dit je
vends en fait pour pouvoir d'accord
récolter des fonds pour pouvoir aider
pour pouvoir faire un don tout
simplement du jeu l'adorent moi je suis
fana voilà c'est pas ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas un maillot ça n'est pas un
lieu demain c'est un body ces deux
acides attendent harmonium tu comprends
ce que je peux dire et sa salle en reste
et ça franchement afida turner boni le à
le adb le hcb le atb d'afida turner cody
ça en val on va le garder et afida merci
en tout cas fidèle vraiment on la
remercie oui parce que nous avons à elle
nous a fait vivre des moments écrite
cholet